schon seit meiner kindheit bin ich
fasziniert von sprachen
ich habe meine eigene erfunden du hast
eine vollständige sprache erfunden
ja ich schrieb geschichten legenden
culkin ist ein film wie wir ihn im
moment sehr häufig zu sehen bekommen
nämlich ein biopic das heißt es werden
biografien genommen von schauspielern
von musikern von schriftstellern und das
soll uns erklärt werden wie kam der
künstler wie kam der schriftsteller wie
kam der musiker zu den werken die ihn
später berühmt gemacht haben und bei
tolkien ist das ganz klar der herr der
ringe und der hobbit
[Musik]
ich verstehe noch werde ich für sein
stellt eine ältere these schon das
talkin einen wesentlichen teil der
bilder für seine romane aus dem ersten
weltkrieg nahm kein beispiel indem der
film auch sehr schwelgt ist die schlacht
und die zerstörungen die damit verbunden
sind einmal schaut tolkien aus dem
graben zum schützengraben und sieht eine
zerstörte landschaft und als zuschauer
denken sie sofort das ist mordor das ist
ein zerstörtes land in dem rein gar
nichts gedeiht oder irgendwann kommen
die deutschen mit ihren flammenwerfern
und belegen den schützengraben mit feuer
und auch da denkt tolkien und dann auch
der zuschauer sofort an einen
feuerspeienden drachen
das ist plausibel man kann diese bilder
sehr wohl übertragen
es zeigt sich aber in dem film dass er
eine gewisse verengung bewirkt das
bedeutet von anfang an geht es um ein
ziel es ist eine gerade linie von dem
erlebten zum schreiben und ganz am ende
sieht man also den tolkien wie er in
großaufnahme dem ersten berühmten satz
von seinem hobby aufschreibt und da muss
ich sagen wird es mir ein bisschen zu
viel mit dieser gradlinigkeit mit dieser
biografie die so ganz als stetige
entwicklung auf ein werk hin gedeutet
wird frühster kindheit bin ich
fasziniert von sprache von ihr besessen
ich habe eigene erfunden umfassende
vollständige sprachen sind es ist alles
aus meinem preis hoch der filmheld im
grunde genommen
beinahe lineal den werdegang des
schülers der zum vollwaisen wird er wird
einquartiert bei einer frau die ihn
aufnimmt und da gibt es noch eine andere
junges mädchen edf
denn die er sich dann verliebt das ist
dann wie spätere frau seiner kinder der
bis ans lebensende zusammenlebte das ist
die liebesgeschichte in dem film dann
gibt es immer noch eine zweite
geschichte nämlich eine
freundschaftliche schuler st
wir verändern die welt durch die macht
der kunst der musik der poesie
was ist mit dreckigen ich nein der vier
mitglieder dieses clubs bleiben dann
später im ersten weltkrieg und auch das
spielt eine große rolle für diesen film
die firma von peter jackson sind ja
bekannt der hat ja den herrn der ringe
verfilmt und den hobbit dann monumental
aufgeblasen eigentlich im verhältnis zu
der vorlage
so etwas muss man hier nicht erwarten
hier geht es eher um einen schon meist
sehr gediegenen kostümfilm der seine
großen bildmächtigen momente tatsächlich
dann in der zeit des ersten weltkriegs
hat aber die schlacht ziehen sind
eigentlich ganz geschickt so angelegt
dass sie eben nicht peter jackson
zitieren das ist tatsächlich ein
eigenständiger filmes und das wiederum
wird man ihm hoch anrechnen
sie handelt von reisen
während für tolkien interessiert der
wird ihm sicherlich mit einem gewissen
interesse sehen vielleicht auch
vergnügen wenn man sich darauf einlässt
auf diese geschichte auf die bilder sind
sehr potente bilder wieder gezeigt
werden wenn man dagegen wenn man durch
einschlägige literatur gelesen hat dann
wird man sagen neues erfahre ich daraus
nicht bestimmte dinge wären sehr
eindeutig beschildert und man hätte sich
ein klein wenig mehr an differenzierung
gewünscht
[Musik]